[Musique]
est-ce que vous connaissez le White out
j'ai pas dit burn out sniper out
j'ai pas dit non plus blackout que
certains ici ont pu peut-être connaître
après des soirées bien arrosées
c'est un phénomène qu'on rencontre dans
les zones polaires ou en montagne c'est
quand la couleur blanche d'un nuage ou
du brouillard se confond sans nuance
avec le blanc de la neige ou de la glace
quand vous vous retrouvez dans le White
out vous n'avez plus aucun repère visuel
de verticalité ou d'horizontalité
votre oreille interne ne fonctionne plus
vous avancez en titubant comme si vous
étiez sous en fait
ça m'est arrivé plusieurs fois lors de
mes différentes expéditions une fois ou
un an ou encore en Antarctique quand je
reliais le Pôle Sud
quand vous faites une expédition polaire
vous pouvez pas vous payer le luxe
d'attendre que la météo s'améliore
il vous faut avancer coûte que coûte car
vous êtes contraint par vos rations de
nourriture
alors comment faire pour avancer quand
on a plus aucun point de repère
écoutez je suis pas né avec le mode
d'emploi et je suis pas d'aventurier
professionnel mais plutôt quelqu'un qui
mène une vie ordinaire et qui en
parallèle même des projets qui sortent
de l'ordinaire
j'ai 50 ans une famille avec ma femme
nous avons deux filles 14 et 16 ans j'ai
un emploi à temps plein et je vis en
région parisienne
et depuis 20 ans je réalise des
expéditions qui m'ont permis d'être le
deuxième français à avoir accompli le
Grand Chelem des explorateurs
à savoir faire l'ascension des seven
Smith dont l'Everest et rallier le pôle
nord et le Pôle Sud nous sommes moins de
100 actuellement dans le monde
quant à moi j'ai démarré de zéro
il m'a fallu découvrir
apprendre patiemment rencontrer les
bonnes personnes essayer de gérer un
équilibre entre ces projets la vie
familiale la vie professionnelle
m'entraîner minutieusement trouver des
sponsors gérer des échecs et gérer aussi
l'alternance des périodes entre
l'isolement l'éloignement et le retour à
la vie urbaine
et voici ce que j'ai appris lors de ces
expéditions et qui peut vous servir pour
toutes vos aventures au quotidien
j'ai d'abord appris à adopter l'état
d'esprit de l'aventurier
même si prépare minutieusement ses
expéditions l'aventurier sait que sur
place rien ne se passera compris
rien ne se passera comme prévu
il sait aussi qu'il n'aura pas de
deuxième chance pour vous mettre dans
l'ambiance d'après vous qu'est-ce qui
m'arrive si je traverse cette masse
couche de glace nous sommes au Pôle Nord
[Applaudissements]
je risque rien
moi l'eau est à 0° et la température
extérieure est de -25 et là c'est pas
comme au cinéma on peut pas la refaire
on peut pas dire pouce maintenant que je
sais bah je vais passer à côté
trop tard
donc
l'aventurier c'est d'anticiper un
maximum de risques mais comme il sait
que sur place il peut pas tout prévoir
il accueille la certitude et s'adapte
aux situations imprévisibles en
acceptant de sortir de sa zone de
confort
facile à dire
si on revient à notre white out
c'est un phénomène connu des hommes
polaires donc je ne peux pas dire que je
suis surpris qu'il advienne mais
franchement pour nous il arrive au pire
moment
ça fait 15 jours que nous marchons et
nous sommes déjà en retard sur notre
programme qui prévoit de couvrir les 650
km jusqu'au pôle Sud en 35 jours
nous avons été immobilisés par la
tempête
confiné 4 jours dans nos temps en état
d'alerte permanent à se demander si
notre tente allait résister au rafales
de vent à plus de 100 km/h avec une
température extérieure de moins 40 je
vous laisse juger
bon vous connaissez tous l'histoire des
trois petits cochons
donc on a repris la marche on commence à
être fatigué à traîner ses charges là de
plus de 80 kilos et on aimerait juste en
fait une journée ensoleillée c'est tout
mais c'est pas ce qui se passe
il fait pas beau et donc du coup nous
devons nous adapter à la à la situation
et faire au mieux avec c'est avec ces
conditions
alors comment faire au mieux
quand on espérerait des meilleures
conditions
le l'instrument le plus utile à
l'aventurier dans le dans le White out
c'est
ça
il vous faut d'abord l'ajuster
nous on va vers le pôle Sud géographique
l'axe de rotation de la Terre l'aiguille
de votre boussole vous indique le pôle
sud magnétique en fait en quelque sorte
c'est comme si vous rapprochiez de votre
but et puis que l'aiguille de la
boussole s'en écarte
une fois notre boussole ajustée
je propose de découvrir ces quatre
points cardinaux qui illustrent 4
principes d'actions des aventuriers
alors comme on va vers le sud commençons
par le sud
au sud il est écrit
accepter sa vulnérabilité
alors c'est vrai que
les milieux extrêmes nous dépassent et
nous propose des conditions sur
lesquelles on ne peut pas agir
confinés dans votre tente vous ne pouvez
pas agir sur la tempête c'est hors de
votre contrôle à quoi bon se dire si au
moins il faisait température plus
agréable ou encore pourquoi hier on n'a
pas essayé de marcher davantage au moins
on aurait pris un peu d'avance
inutile de perdre de l'énergie
il vous faut apprendre à vous concentrer
sur les éléments sur lesquels vous
pouvez agir ici et maintenant
alors dans le White out qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire on peut faire plein de choses
on peut réduire les relais pour gérer la
fatigue on peut se mettre à deux pour
sécuriser un CAP ou encore on peut
ajuster les objectifs de distance à
parcourir tous les jours et mieux encore
on peut essayer de garder le moral voilà
mais c'est comme ça donc tant qu'on
avance c'est le principal étant qu'on va
dans la bonne direction c'est le plus
important
bon là je dois vous avouer que je fais
le malin j'ai mis plus d'une demi-heure
à les rattraper en fait ça fait un petit
peu avouer qu'on voit de poids lourd sur
l'autoroute un autre histoire
donc
accepter les éléments tels qu'ils
arrivent
nécessite effectivement donc de faire la
part des choses entre ce sur quoi vous
réagir et ce sur quoi vous ne pouvez pas
agir
en quelque sorte la meilleure réponse
qu'on puisse apporter à ces situations
c'est que chacun mette ses points forts
au service du collectif
si un coéquipier est en difficulté c'est
toute l'équipe qui est en difficulté moi
aussi je suis en difficulté j'ai donc
intérêt à l'aider même si il faut
reconnaître j'en ai pas très envie ou
encore je suis un petit peu fatigué moi
aussi
donc
prendre conscience de cette
vulnérabilité vous aide en quelque sorte
à dépasser les intérêts individuels et
finalement
renforce les liens d'interdépendance au
sein de l'équipe
allez
à l'est il est écrit faire avec les
moyens du bord
faire avec les moyens du bord
c'est vrai que les expéditions polaires
vont pousser à la sobriété tout
simplement parce que c'est vous qui
portez tout votre équipement dans le sac
à dos ou dans le traîneau
quand vous préparez les choses vous
chassez le superflu vous concentrez sur
l'essentiel vous évitez le au cas où en
ayant bien conscience que sur place si
vous manque quelque chose il y aura pas
de magasin alimentaire ni de magasin de
sport et encore moins de services de
livraison à domicile
comme rien ne se passe comme prévu en
situation vous faites avec ce que vous
avez
si par exemple vous commencez à manquer
de nourriture vous rationner si lors de
la tempête une des deux tentes explose
vous réfugier dans celle qui reste
mais parfois
l'inattendues arrivent
et là ça devient plus compliqué
imaginez vous êtes au milieu du
Groenland à plus de 10 jours de marche
du premier village
et là l'une des fixations de votre
chaussure casse
vous pouvez plus avancer
ça arrive jamais mais là ça vous arrive
alors c'est d'abord un peu la panique la
peur s'installe on pense à l'ours
polaire qui pour attaquer ou la tempête
qui pourrait se lever on se fait
quelques reproches mutuelles
et pourquoi donc ici dans cette équipe
personne n'a prévu de prendre une paire
de rechange de chaussures de rechange
c'est simple donc
alors il faut trouver des solutions
chacun ouvre son sac regarde à
l'intérieur et peut-être qu'on va
trouver quelque chose qui fera l'affaire
et figurez-vous que l'un d'entre nous
trouvait un rouleau de scotch qui sert
habituellement à emballer les cartons de
déménagement
pourquoi avoir pris ce genre de scotch
avait-il prévu de déménager une fois la
traversée du Groenland
inutile de répondre autant se concentrer
sur la solution et regardez ce que nous
avons réussi à faire
ingénieux non
comme quoi un simple bout de scotch peut
vous sauver une vie
en tout cas ça vous apprend à faire avec
ce que vous avez
identifiez toutes les ressources à votre
disposition et les utiliser les
optimiser avant de chercher en acquérir
frénétiquement de nouvelles
à l'ouest
à l'ouest il est écrit une connerie par
jour
mais jamais deux fois la même
une connerie par jour mais jamais deux
fois la même bon bah c'est ce qui nous
est arrivé au Groenland encore une fois
sur une calotte glaciaire si vous
laissez un ski poser à plat sur la glace
et disparaît très vite on se veut lit
par la neige qui est poussé par les
vents de surface
à la fin d'une journée quand vous avez
marché 10 heures vous avez hâte que
d'une chose c'est de monter le camp et
vous réfugier à l'intérieur de l'attente
difficile de rester concentré sur ce que
vous faites de vos skis
alors à cause de ça on a perdu un
premier skin une première fois
qu'on a retrouvé le lendemain matin en
retournant tout le camp à l'appel à
neige
première connerie
et quelques jours plus tard
on a perdu un deuxième ski
et celui-là on l'a pas retrouvé
deuxième connerie la même
il suffisait juste de planter les skis à
la verticale
alors heureusement on n'avait pas de
chaussures de rechange mais on avait des
skis de rechange
donc à prendre de ses erreurs c'est pas
si facile il faut les identifier et puis
mettre en place des solutions donc
depuis ce jour on a décidé de mettre en
place un rituel quotidien tous les soirs
on s'est posés 4 questions c'est la
méthode qui se peut être pour ceux qui
connaissent ici
K comme keep qu'est-ce qu'on fait bien
et qu'il faut continuer demain l'idée
c'est de consolider ses points forts i
comme il prouve qu'est-ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui et sur lequel il faut
s'améliorer demain progresser start mais
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pas aujourd'hui
qu'il faut faire demain expérimenter
et stop
qu'est-ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui qu'il
vaut mieux arrêter sinon ça devient de
la stupidité
donc prendre conscience de sa
vulnérabilité vous aide en fait à
ajuster le niveau d'exigence à la
situation ça permet aussi le droit à
l'erreur à chacun une connerie par jour
et surtout bah ça vous motive à
apprendre au plus vite pour éviter de la
de la renouveler jamais deux fois la
même
au nord
au nord il est écrit suivre son étoile
polaire
suivre son étoile polaire
peut-être que depuis tout à l'heure vous
vous demandez pourquoi je fais tout ça
pourquoi passer 35 jours dans des
températures de moins de 30 ou moins 40
pourquoi les risques et sa vie au sommet
de l'Est pourquoi encore aller sur le
territoire de l'ours qui ne ferait
qu'une bouchée de vous si jamais vous le
croisiez
j'ai beaucoup de réponses à cette
question et j'ai envie d'en partager une
qui me semble la plus importante pour
nous tous ici
de concrétiser des rêves d'enfants
l'envie en vie
c'est une force incroyable qui vous
permet de traiter la question corollaire
à tout rêve qu'est-ce que je suis prêt à
faire pour le rendre possible
quand j'étais enfant je lisais des
livres d'aventuriers et j'avais qu'une
envie en fait c'est d'aller découvrir
les milieux décrits ressentir par
moi-même aller au sommet de l'Everest
pour voir ce que ça fait que d'être
quasiment à l'altitude du vol d'un avion
aller au Pôle Nord marcher sur la
banquise morceau de glace qui flotte et
qui dérive atteindre le pôle et essayer
d'en faire le tour et voir si
éventuellement ça fait remonter le temps
aller au pôle Sud et
voir ce que ça fait que d'avoir la tête
en bas
ok chacun ses rêves
mais du rêve à la réalité il m'a fallu
attendre l'âge de mes 30 ans
le déclic a été que je m'ennuyais dans
mon travail et j'étais à la recherche
d'un second souffle professionnel et en
plus je me rendais compte que j'avais
mis de côté tous ces rêves d'enfants
alors j'ai fait l'exercice de la lettre
du vieux sage et ça m'a aidé à prendre à
décision de me donner les moyens de
concrétiser mes rêves les plus chers
vous connaissez peut-être cet exercice
la lettre du vieux sage
alors c'est une coach qui me l'a proposé
il s'agit en fait de se projeter à la
veille de votre mort quel que soit votre
âge de vous retourner sur votre vie et
de vous poser la question suivante
je vais mourir demain
et quand je regarde ma vie je suis fier
de quoi
puis à vous de compléter votre propre
lettre
bon moi la mienne elle devait être un
peu longue si j'en juge la réaction de
la coach quand elle a lu
elle a regardé elle m'a dit
et vous comptez vivre 150 ans vous
puis pourquoi ça rentre pas dans une vie
tout ça
elle m'a dit non
il va falloir fixer des priorités et
faire des choix
alors il m'a fallu faire des choix
identifier ce dont j'avais le plus envie
et aussi passer à l'action en ayant bien
conscience que le plus dur serait
sûrement de faire le premier pas et
peut-être même d'ailleurs
les suivre
et à force de persévérance
par rapport j'ai réussi à gravir tous
ces sommets et atteindre les deux pôles
qu'est-ce que je veux vraiment
qu'est-ce que je suis prêt à faire pour
l'obtenir
quel sens je veux donner à ma vie
qu'elle capte je décide de me fixer
les réponses ne sont pas si évidentes
alors pour ma part j'ai trouvé cette
citation de Jean Giono qui m'accompagne
sur l'ensemble de mes expéditions
si tu n'arrives pas à penser marche
si tu penses trop
marge
et si tu penses mal
marcher encore
vous l'avez bien compris je continue de
marcher
c'est une véritable exploration
intérieure
et vous
malgré la certitude
est-ce que vous gardez toujours cette
envie d'avancer est-ce que vous gardez
toujours cette envie de concrétiser les
rêves qui sont les plus chers
à chacun son Everest
à chacun son rêve
et je souhaite que cette boussole et ses
quatre points cardinaux vous accompagne
et vous donne quelques points de repère
je vous souhaite à toutes et à tous de
très très belles explorations
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]